hey everybody welcome to ask a career
coach today is Thursday February 14th
and it is Valentine's Day so we're gonna
have a real love fest love themed
conversation today about how you find a
career that you actually love I'm really
excited to chat with you all we're
collecting your questions in the chat
here
Karen will be forwarding all of your
amazing questions to me and I will be
addressing them throughout this call our
first topic of course we always kick
these off with a little bit of a topic
is going to be how do I find a career I
love but Before we jump into that we're
going to give a few minutes for folks to
join the call join the the YouTube live
if you know anyone who is searching for
a job right now for them this link maybe
they can join us last minute and get
some of their career questions answered
super excited talk to you today I'll
give you a little bit of background on
myself for those of you who are new I
know a lot of you join us every single
week but my name is Martin McGovern I'm
a career advisor here at Udacity
and my background is primarily in
marketing personal branding career
development and how to get noticed for
the things that you want to do so a lot
of us are here trying to figure out you
know how do I get this job how do I
reach out to recruiters how do I build
my network how do I interview well those
are the things that we want to be
talking about on this cul I don't have a
programming background so there are some
of these technical topics that I might
be able to give some overview on some
high-level thoughts around but when we
get into the nitty-gritty of like coding
interviews and things like that that's
what we want to bring in the the
programming experts but for our
conversation today we're going to be
talking a lot about how to you know go
through this career journey in a way
that works best for you how do you meet
the right people how do you interview in
a way that showcases your skillset how
do you build an online presence all of
these are topics that we're going to go
into so I'm really excited to collect
your questions and dig into them today
we will be giving it just a few more
minutes here as we wait for folks to
join so it gives you ample time to let
us know where you're joining us from
what time it is by you I know a lot of
you are joining us like 1:00 in the
morning and different parts of the world
which is super crazy and awesome and I
thank you for joining us and you know
what's your weather like we got it's
actually pretty warm in Chicago today
all this snow and ice of the ice
apocalypse has melted a bit and yeah I'm
super excited to jump in with you all
today's thank you so much for joining us
and taking the time to ask questions and
and be part of this conversation we got
a good amount of people joining I think
we're crossing over the 40 mark here so
we'll give it just a couple more minutes
and to kick things off
Karen threw a question in the chat here
chocolate or flowers what is your
Valentine's Day preference what what are
the things that you love for me it's
chocolate I'm not all day all day
chocolate over flowers - what is the
best chocolate candy that's it it's a
big question is it Twix is it Snickers
KitKat's what's your favorite chocolate
maybe just a dove bar those are pretty
darn good all right let's see where
everyone is joining from we got Romania
how are things in Romania today happy
Valentine's to you as well Jim uh-huh
Elena I believe that I pronounce your
name I happy Valentine's Day I prefer
pizza 100% agree with you I'm in Chicago
and pizza is the definitely better
choice over chocolate flowers as a
matter of fact if you're in Chicago and
I'm assuming other cities as well you
can get a pizza in the shape of a heart
from Lou Malnati's I believe if you like
deep-dish I definitely recommend that as
a way to go I did that last year
all right we got Pakistan this video
will be recorded thank you for asking
it's actually being recorded as we speak
and I typically like to chop up some
questions from here and post them
separately as well so keep an eye out
for those algeria pakistan it is 1:00 in
the morning in pakistan 1 a.m. in india
hello from france thanks for joining us
hello from greece
all right we're
some people talking about their career
shifts Ipek obviously chocolate in
Pakistan thank you
it's Iranian New Delhi and it's 1:30 in
the morning in India all right we're
getting a lot of votes for chocolate
Swiss chocolate Swiss chocolate is
amazing ah Terry's chocolate hello from
Egypt magnums yep all right
magnums are pretty good I like other
layer in the caramel in there that's
definitely the way to do it
India's Saudi Arabia Hershey's yeah
Hershey's we actually have a Hershey
store in Chicago I think we can get
those giant I want to get one of those
giant Kit Kats like basically a bar
bigger than my head we got turkey New
York Romania Cameroon another vote for
pizza I like this I like everyone in
this chat already chocolate pizza all
day all right we're getting some
questions in Sudan Germany Mississippi
Vancouver our topic for the discussion
today I'm looking through the chat here
our topic is how to find a career you
love and but of course we're open to
talking about anything that's on your
mind today so if you have career
questions or on the interview career
questions around how to build an online
presence how to network things like that
we can definitely dig into those as well
today
Georgia turkey Nigeria Iran all right it
looks like we've got a great turnout
here today and we're gonna be jumping
into our questions in just a second
apparently Japan is crazy about Kit Kats
that's awesome
all right I love it Brazil let's jump in
and today we are talking about pizza
that's gonna be the entire topic
actually no I'm just getting around
start putting your questions in the chat
like I said Karen will be sending those
my way as we go through the conversation
here and we're gonna be talking
initially about how to find a career
that you love so kicking off with that
question how do I find a career I love
there's a lot of talk in the world today
about finding your passion and if you're
not living your passion you're not doing
it right
and it's one of those things that is
just becoming so over talked about that
people are feeling this pressure to live
up to this passion this quote-unquote
passion and they're starting to you know
have FOMO and have fear around this idea
it's supposed to be an idea that you
know motivates you and gets you moving
in a direction that you like maybe if
you're unhappy in your career searching
for your passion would be cyber that
maybe if you're unhappy in your career
searching for your passion would be
something that could be motivating
however because it's gone so far down
the road in this conversation
we have people panicking because they
feel like if I don't find my passion my
life is over and that's just not true
there are a lot of things in life and
our passions grow and change and evolve
and there's a lot of great value that
you can bring to the world without
getting too caught up in this idea of
passion and this is what I really want
to start the conversation off with
because in both work and in our love
life there's this concept of the one
right I need to find the one the one the
one company the one job the one person
that will satisfy everything in my life
and fulfill every single thing that I
need in my career and then and so on and
so forth and this concept of the one
typically ends up backfiring when people
are trying to chase too hard after one
thing when we get so caught up in this
idea that there is one answer and that
answer is going to solve everything
we end up missing out on the truth which
is it's a lit there's a lot of options
in this world and there's a lot of
different things that you can do that
will help you in your career help you in
your life and bring value to the world
and so almost all the conversations that
I have with people I ask them you know
where would you like to work and almost
everyone gives me the same answers I
want to work at Google Facebook etc
right the biggest names in the game and
if I can't get a job there well then why
am I even trying and the truth of the
matter is is that while those are great
companies you want to be thinking much
bigger than that you want to open up
your options and figure out that life is
more about the journey than just ending
up at one of these places so I would
recommend stop looking for the one quote
unquote and just start looking for
places where you can be valuable and
that's important because it's not about
getting that one thing because even when
you get that one thing chances are your
brain will go great now I have it I want
the next thing like I really want a
KitKat all right I just ate a KitKat now
I want ice cream right there's always
something else that we want to chase
after so stop looking for the one and
start reframing it as who do I want to
help who do I want to bring value to in
this world what companies and industries
do I want to support because I think
that they're having a beneficial
influence in the world and this goes to
the idea of giving more than you get in
your career when we're doing a job
search it's a very me focused process we
say I really want to get a job and then
we go network and we go talk to people
we say hi my name is Martin and I want a
job give me a job why aren't you giving
me a job the world owes me a job but the
truth of the matter is if you don't
provide value if you don't showcase how
you provide value well why why would
someone just give you a job we want we
want to be out there not saying give me
something we want to be out there saying
how can I help how can I be of service
to what you're trying to account
because every company that hires someone
needs an employee every company that
brings someone on needs that person to
bring value to their big mission their
big goals and if you can communicate how
you bring value to your goal to their
goals you're going to stand out so much
more than anyone else and think about it
in a relationship as well right because
this is Valentine's Day and we are
talking about everything right
everything from our life to our work and
if you go into a relationship and all
you want is to take all you want is to
get get get and you never give well that
relationship isn't going to last very
long and the same with your career if
all you're trying to do is get stuff out
of your career
get stuff for you for you you're not
gonna be able to go as far and find that
quote-unquote career you love because
you're not actually putting the effort
back in and showing how you provide
value and grow and help them grow and
then they help you girl and it goes back
and forth right and this brings us to
the next idea which is don't get too
caught up in trying to find the perfect
role right we're moving out beyond that
idea of the one we're trying to give
more than we get and then when it comes
to being happy in your job it's more of
a ratio thing than it is a solid yes or
no and I like this concept of the 80/20
rule for happiness if you're looking at
your career in 80% of what you're doing
is something you dislike and only 20% is
something you like that's an issue we
need to work on that we need to start
moving in the direction where we can get
closer to an 80/20 positive ratio so 80%
of what I do is what I like but no job
is perfect so of course there's about
20% where I'm doing the day-to-day
activities I'm just trying to you know
do my taxes or whatever the thing is
that's coming up so when you're thinking
about being happy in your career it's
less about trying to find a career you
love and more about trying to find a
good ratio of things that I like versus
things that I need to get done in order
to keep doing what I like right so no
person is perfect no job is perfect but
if you can get to get closer to that 82
any ratio might be a good place to start
in trying to pursue this career that you
love and then when you're in your next
job or wherever it may be small company
big company you know doing exactly what
you want to do or being a few steps away
from that role that dream job that you
want to have always practice gratitude a
lot of times we get into the mindset of
maximizing everything we we need to be
moving to the next thing moving to the
next thing moving to the next thing but
we never really stop and be grateful for
where we're at right so when you're
looking at everything and you're trying
to build this career that you love
gratitude is going to be one of the
biggest things that you need to focus on
in order to get to the next stage to
keep a positive mindset if every time
you apply for a job and they say no we
we go down this road of pessimism we're
not gonna be able to you know keep
things moving we have to be grateful for
the chance for the next opportunity so
maybe this one didn't work but I was
grateful that I got a chance to try now
let's go after another one and that's
how we're gonna end up getting a job
that you love by both continuing to move
forward being grateful for the
opportunities that come your way and
then continuing to grow and provide
value so I hope that that's a great like
starting point to ground our discussion
uh in and get it a little bit out of the
clouds and and down on in to reality
because the truth of the matter is is
the job search is tough and that's why
we're here to support you
to help you keep a realistic frame of
reference and to keep your perspective
positive as you're going down this road
towards building a life and a career
that you love alright now we're going to
get into your questions and we're going
to learn a little bit about what's on
your mind
and how we can help you in your career
for students our first
is from Diego what about right let me
see here I'm trying to make sure I
understand your question what about not
doing a career shift but doing a double
career or a tech powered career but not
a direct connection with technology like
urban planning with data science skills
do any recommendations I'm actually not
entirely sure I understand your question
would you mind rephrasing that a little
bit to be a little bit more clear and
putting it back on the chat I think what
you're saying is I'm not trying to shift
from one career to another but I'm
trying to move towards more technology
within my current career I would
appreciate if you could just make that a
little bit more clear and try and we'll
try and revisit that Diego but I
appreciate your question a Siddharth
Siddharth Siddharth asks I'm really
confused about which career to choose
how can I choose this is an awesome
question making choices in life is very
difficult we really don't know the
outcome when we're making these
decisions and so when you're trying to
figure out which career to choose I'd be
very curious if you have more context
about what you're trying to choose
between but chances are you know you're
at a crossroads or a fork in the road
and you're saying I could go this
direction or I could go that direction
and we we need to get to a point where
we have at least some information about
those two choices typically what ends up
happening is people go I've heard about
this career and I've heard about this
career and I'm I'm not really sure what
they entail but this one sounds better
so I'm going to go after it like this is
what happens with like people who go to
law school and then find out they don't
want to be lawyers or you know they
don't ever really realize what goes into
that job they only see the facade that
exists online so a lot of
people in programming specifically read
articles about how much money
programmers make and choose to become a
programmer because they want to make the
money I personally don't think that's a
great way to find a career that you love
because you're motivated by things that
aren't going to keep you motivated as
you continue moving down that road at a
certain point when you're going in day
after day after day if you don't enjoy
that work to some degree or you're not
curious about it it's gonna get harder
and harder to do it even if the paycheck
is coming in so when you're trying to
figure out a career to choose I would
number one try and pursue your curiosity
so you want to think about what am I not
really curious about what are the things
what are the things that I do as hobbies
what are the things that I'm just
naturally drawn to and interested in
then you need to verify if you're
actually interested in that so for
instance if you want to become a data
scientist it's essential that you go
talk to data scientists and ask them
what their day-to-day lives look like
because on paper it might look like one
thing but in reality it might look like
something completely different and that
might be something that you love but it
might also be something that you know
you really don't relate to or really
don't find interest in and so I would do
that if you're really confused about
which career to choose go talk to five
or six people in each one of those
career paths who are currently doing it
and try and learn a little bit about
what they love about their work and what
they don't like so much about it and
you'll find out pretty quickly if it's
right for you so that's the first part
that's how you start that's how you just
get enough information and then once you
have information on how both these
career paths look in reality in the day
to day grind then you just need to
choose something there really is no way
to know if you're making the right
choice or not before you make it because
you won't it won't be until you're in it
until you're doing it every day that you
really know if this is something that
you enjoy
and you might do it for a few years and
then change your mind maybe your your
priorities shift or your interest shift
that's fine you can always switch down
the road there's you know we all have
very very long careers these days you
know it even if you're in your 40s it's
you've still got you know 20 to 30 years
you know of work ahead of you that's a
lot of time and so we don't get too
caught up in worrying about every
individual choice just spend a lot of
time thinking about directionally does
this help me move towards the direction
that I'm interested in am i curious
about it I can always shift as I
continue to move forward so I hope
that's helpful in making that decision
be curious follow that curiosity and
then get realistic information for
people who currently do that job in
order to make sure it's something you
wanted to do you want to do just to give
a fun example back in college in high
school I was part of a band and it was a
scout band and no one knows the skies
but it was this fun little band and we
would meet on you know nights and
weekends we'd play some shows we would
do little things like that and a part of
me thought maybe I'll be a you know I'll
be in a band maybe that'll be the career
that I follow and then I went and
actually saw what it's like to be on
tour and to be sleeping in hotels all
the time and you know never have a go a
residence and I was like actually I
don't want to be in a band that's that's
not the lifestyle that I'm hoping to to
live out and so because I got that
actual information I was able to make a
choice to not pursue that it sounds
romantic in your head to you know be in
a band but when you actually look at the
day-to-day is that something you're
willing to do and that's what's really
important in order to make decisions
all right incredible joy asks what
should you do if your city or region has
very few deep learning jobs I know there
are people who work in the field but I
don't really see the jobs advertised
it's a very good question incredible joy
thank you for asking it the first thing
I would say is you need to make sure so
you said I know there are people who
work in the field but I don't really see
the jobs advertised just because they're
not advertised doesn't mean they don't
exist if people are working in that
position in your area that means those
jobs exist maybe there aren't as many
the bad just means you have to try a
little harder to network your way in so
here's what I would do I would go to
LinkedIn I would go to the people search
I would type in the filter I would put
in the you know deep learning is the job
title or whatever the job title is that
you want to have filter by your city and
then look at the list of people who come
up there should probably be a couple
hundred in there at least you want to
look at the companies that these people
work at and how and then reach out and
network with these people so all those
people that show up on that list those
are going to be the people who those
going to be the companies that maybe
you've never heard of that maybe don't
have anything advertised but they've
hired people for deep learning before
that's going to be important because
then you make that list of companies you
put it off to the side you set alerts
for any jobs that might come up you
start networking with as many people in
those companies as you possibly can and
eventually you find a way in and if
that's really really what you want to be
doing maybe you have to do something
else to get your foot in or intern or
contract or whatever the thing might be
and then worst case scenario let's say
there are no jobs in your area then you
have to make a choice is this what you
really want to be doing or do you want
your location over the job if there are
truly no jobs in your location you need
to either change your location or change
the job you're going after one of those
two things is it's going to be a tough
choice it's going to be a very difficult
choice to make and I don't know your
life situation or anything like that but
if there are no jobs in your area you
need to go to an area that has those
jobs or you need to change what it is
that you want to do and I know that's
kind of a harsh thing to say but it's
it's kind of where you're at if that's
truly the case I don't believe that's
the case I think there are companies in
your area you just might need to try a
little harder to find them because there
they may not be loud and advertising but
those are kind of the things that go
through my head thank you so much for
your question
alright Diego I would like to develop a
career in urban planning but strongly
powered by data science when I tell
people I'm learning data science people
do not understand wah hi how can I
better tell my story of merging data
science with urban planning so that
others can see my value this is a great
question it's very difficult to explain
something complicated in an initial
conversation so the question I would ask
you is what are all the areas in which
data science can help the world of urban
planning make a list of all those areas
it can help with Road designs it can
help with where you place buildings that
can help with you know the sewer system
right I'm sure it can help with a
million different things when it comes
to urban planning now how do you share
that information with the world we can
try and do it with one-on-one
conversations very quickly at networking
events and interviews and things like
that or we can organize our thoughts and
share them systematically so I would
take your list of ideas here is how data
science can help urban planning and
break it out by topic and then create
articles on medium or LinkedIn articles
in the publishing platform create either
a podcast or YouTube videos different
things like that and start putting those
out on your linkedin and your twitter or
whatever it is that you use for social
networking and what that will do is it
will not only help you know one by one
change people's thinking around how data
science can help in this area but it
also positions you as an expert around
that topic so then when someone says
well how does this how can data science
impact urban planning you can send them
your this is how data science impacts
urban planning article or video and then
they'll get you know down the rabbit
hole watching all your videos this is
how it helps a sewage system this is how
it helps you know the roads this is how
it helps X Y & Z and I'm
making all this stuff up but that is how
you start to reposition yourself and
also educate people that this is an
important thing to think about and then
when you go in for an interview when
they google you all these things come up
when they look at your LinkedIn all
these things are there and they go wow
this person really knows what they're
doing let's bring it on and see what we
can do this is actually a term called
content networking and it's something
that I think is absolutely amazing it's
I mean that's literally what we're doing
right here right I'm I'm getting to know
all of you through these questions we're
recording this and then we're gonna
share it out more and it's gonna get
these ideas out to more people so I
definitely recommend doing something
along those lines in order to reposition
yourself thank you so much for question
data
all right NJ I have a job an IT that I
don't enjoy I'm passionate about finance
and investment but I don't have much
education since I didn't major in it how
do I switch career paths now all right
so I love this question thank you so
much for asking it the first thing you
need to do is figure out what you need
to have in order to move into that
industry do you need certain
certifications are there any barriers
like actual barriers to getting it for a
lot of people that's like I need a
certification I need to go back to
school different stuff like that but for
a lot of industries you don't need that
stuff and a key thing here is you say
you're passionate about finance and
investment I'd be curious you know going
a little deeper into that what does that
passion look like how do you act it out
right and so if you don't have if you
don't need any certifications or
anything I would just start building
something on the side now let's say you
know finance and investment may be
something that you do is help all your
friends you know sort out their budgets
or you you help people get out of debt
or whatever the thing is that you might
be doing in the finance world how do you
get that more organized as a side
project what we like to call a side
hustle in order to start building up
your expertise in an area and then
eventually hopefully over time you can
allow that to grow and eclipse what
you're currently doing and you can make
a switch so to give an example I used to
work in marketing and on the side I
started helping people build their
personal brands started helping small
businesses build their corporate brands
started helping people with their career
development started coaching and so
here's my marketing career here's my
coaching career and then they met and
suddenly I went from being a marketer
who does a little bit of career coaching
to a career coach who does some
marketing and eventually the career
coaching Eclipse the marketing and now
they kind of go
and forth a little bit sometimes I'm
coaching sometimes I'm marketing it all
depends on the project and the knee and
that's how you sort of build out a path
from your current job to your next job
because it's going to take time to
switch your your image the way people
know you things like that and again this
goes back to sharing things on your
Linkedin to updating maybe you create a
new a new experience piece on your
LinkedIn where it says you know
financial advisor and I'm helping people
with budgets or I'm investing in these
stocks or different things like that and
that's how people sort of build out a
side hustle that helps them make a
career transition now if all you need to
do is get a certification and then start
applying to jobs that certification that
also works but again you got to sort of
switch your image on LinkedIn and
different social networks and works
people for people to start thinking of
you as a finance person rather than an
IT person
alright gem I am working as an analyst
for clinical trials but I want to do
something more innovative I'm not sure
exactly what that looks like I have not
figured out where my next jump is so I'm
learning new skills and applying them to
my current work will that be a good
strategy to help me determine what to do
next
I'm very curious to know a little bit
more about what these new skills are
that you're learning but I would assume
if you're learning new things and
applying it to your work that it's going
to help you figure out where you want to
go next
so let's what we really need to do with
this question is figure out what you
mean by more innovative what are some of
the things that you are seeing that are
happening in the real world that are
innovative that you are excited about
you know could be self-driving cars it
could be any number of things
what are they can you list them out and
then can you see where those companies
are looking for analysts so you can
literally go back into that search we
did on LinkedIn and you can add in
industries and so if there are certain
industries that you think are incredibly
innovative that's where you want to
start looking filtered by those
industries and see which ones hire
analysts probably a lot of them if
they're quite innovative technology
technologically so if the clinical trial
world isn't let's say focus enough on
technology or innovative enough that's
when we need to start saying all right
what companies and what industries are
and when you start writing things down
and getting it out of your head and
being hyper specific about what you're
hoping to do next that's when things
start happening when we live in this
sort of fantasy about oh I just want to
be more innovative
it doesn't really hold any water because
if I asked you well how are you going to
innovate it might come
if I hire you and you just say I'm just
gonna be more innovative I'm gonna say I
don't know what that means
and then we're not gonna really get
anywhere but if you say I'm gonna be
innovative by taking my analyst training
and coming up with new ideas that solve
problem one problem to problem three now
we're on to something all right
great well let's go innovate let's go
attack those problems solve them create
something new and that's going to be
what really propels you to this next
next place so keep doing what you're
doing keep learning new skills and then
really get specific about what problems
those new skills can solve and if you
can solve problems people who move out
of your way and let you be innovative
right uh uh uh how can I find what I'm
good at
with fewer tries and less time less time
than doing multiple internships etc this
is a great question this is where little
side projects help a lot the way that
I've done it and the way I've seen a lot
of people do it is that they build sort
of a like a an all-encompassing side
project where they can do anything they
want
for me it was called idea lemon and we
hosted networking events we help people
with personal branding we their personal
brands we talk courses we you know held
Pizza dinners we did all sorts of
different things and it would change on
an on a regular basis what we were
trying to do but it all stayed under
this one like umbrella let's say and it
allowed us to kind of quickly build
things on our own and try things and
then realize oh I'm actually not really
good at that or I don't really enjoy
that and move on to the next thing one
thing we realized that we we tried to
create a journaling like a little
five-day journal kind of a thing and we
realized like oh you know creating
actual physical products it's not really
our strong suit we're much better in the
education space right and so that's one
thing that you can do rather than trying
to get other people to give you things
to work on coming up with things on your
own so I would highly recommend rather
than trying to get out there and get a
bunch of internships and do a bunch of
things like that instead come up with a
project of your own and test out your
ideas quickly so i'm i really like an
internship at i don't know amazon
creating voice apps for one of these you
know Alexis please what's always tries
talking um instead just try and write
some of your own voice apps at home and
you're either good at it or you're not
good at it you're you enjoy it and
you're curious about it or you're not
and you don't have to wait for Amazon to
give you that internship you can just do
it on your own so there's a lot of
opportunity in our world right now to
just build stuff on your own so I would
start there if you just want to move
through things quickly and figure out
what you enjoy and what you're good at
try and build it yourself if you try and
build something from the ground up you
will learn very quickly if it's
something you enjoy and are good at
alright
Aditi I'm a graduate student pursuing a
master's in computer science while
looking for software development
internships I usually apply online on
LinkedIn however I don't happen to
receive calls from anyone only one out
of every 25 what am I doing wrong
this is a great question of DT you're
really I wouldn't use the word wrong
you're not doing anything wrong you're
doing what you were told to do because
companies like LinkedIn zip recruiter
indeed they tell you if you just use our
software we will find you a job
truth of the matter is 80% of jobs are
found by personal connections so if you
don't have a personal connection when
you apply for this job
your resume goes into the digital filter
or to the button somewhere in the middle
of the big stack of resumes right what
you need to do is build connections
build inroads meet people who work at
these companies so they can pull your
name out of the pile and put it on top
there is just so much competition in
this world right now for internships and
different opportunities that we just get
lost in the shuffle it doesn't mean
you're bad it doesn't mean you don't
have the skills or experience it doesn't
mean any of that stuff it just means
that there's too much information for
the people who are making hiring
decisions to sort through so think about
it from their perspective and this goes
back to our idea of giving more than
you're trying to get if you're in a
giving mode if you're an I want to help
you mode then you're not trying to get a
job from a company you're trying to help
them hire the best person who have
to be you right and so when you think
about how can I help the hiring manager
make this decision easier how can I help
them by showing them it's a no brainer
to bring me on right maybe you work for
a little less money maybe you you know
maybe you make it very clear how your
skill set helps them solve certain
problems maybe you create an online
presence that is so complete and so
human that when they google you they go
wow this person is clearly gonna fit in
here I don't even need to interview them
although you'll still probably get an
interview go through the interview
process so there's a lot of different
things that you can do but stuff but I
would encourage you to switch your
thinking from what am I doing wrong
- how can I make this easier for the
hiring manager and usually that's a
personal reference or something along
those lines that makes it them more
confident and bringing you on full-time
or as an internship so let's just try
and shift to that thinking from what am
I doing wrong - how can I help and that
will definitely increase your chances
and you're you're very very likely going
to need to go out and build a network in
order to get into these jobs
all right our next question is from Deb
Yan Xiu I'm so sorry I'm terrible at
pronouncing names hope I got close
should we be applying too should we be
applying directly on a company site or
use angel co and other job portals I'm
confused about which is better I don't
believe it's more be careful of this
answer I think it really doesn't matter
where the application comes from it
matters how they are going to know to
pull you out and interview on the other
side so this relates to our last
question our last answer if you know
someone who works at the company they
can pass your information along to the
hiring manager they can help you get
pulled out of the pile if you don't then
really any of the job portals will work
or will be will be I'm not gonna say
they work but it's like they're all kind
of on the same playing field let's just
put it that way
so you should definitely be applying on
LinkedIn and indeed an angel deck oh I
wouldn't apply to both so if it's listed
on indeed and LinkedIn I wouldn't go
through both portals for the same job
just pick a portal and go with it but
then once you've applied make sure you
start meeting people at that company so
you can get pulled in get a personal
reference for that job so don't worry so
much about where you're putting in your
application it all goes to the same
place the people that are hiring
I'll get that information and they have
to sort through it on their end so of
course it's gonna vary depending on the
company and the person instead of
worrying about that spend more time
worrying about how I can meet someone
who can put in a good word for me so
that I can get in to that company
because that's really where it's gonna
come from most of the time I don't know
as a as a career coach we tend to think
of online job portals as black holes
where people just keep sending stuff and
never hearing back now that's not always
the case people get jobs through those
sites but it's much more effective to go
and meet people and build a network to
get it
all right our next question is from Ali
what would be the best answer to the
following interview question in the
event that you do not receive this offer
what do you think would be the reason
hmm I've never seen this question before
in the event that you do not receive an
offer from us what would you think would
be the reason this question is
interesting because it's it's giving you
an opportunity to double down on an
answer that explains a weakness you feel
you might have so like let's reframe
this question you know a lot of times
the last like what are your strengths
and what are your weaknesses that's
really what they're trying to assess
here is how aware are you of your
weaknesses and what are you doing in
order to find work that doesn't rely on
those weaknesses or manage those
weaknesses that you can still get the
job done so in the event that you do not
receive an offer from us what do you
think would be the reason hmm it's also
kind of difficult against this without
knowing the context of what you're
trying to get but I don't know I think I
think this is an area where you want to
dig into your strengths and your
weaknesses you want to dig into your you
know background educational history you
want to dig into a number of different
things around those topics and then
start thinking about well how do I
manage my weaknesses how do I showcase
that I can still get the job done
even if there are some things because
there's a lot of times we're at the end
of an interview someone as the interview
II you can ask what would be something
that you think would prevent me from
getting this job I've heard of people
asking that question in interviews as
well and then they say oh well you know
we're maybe a little worried about your
management experience and then you get a
chance but because they brought that up
to double-down
well my actual my history with
management has been X Y or Z or give a
different example that shows your
leadership skills or you know you get to
address it a little bit more clearly so
in this one I almost see this as an
opportunity to go back and fix any of
the answers that you've given before
that you think might have been weak
answers and double down on why you think
you're strong or double down on giving
context to something that might be
missing in order for you to get that
role so let's say you don't have another
years of experience you'd say well I
think there might be a chance that I
don't have the quote-unquote required
experience for this role however I do
think that the side projects that I've
worked on and the programs that I've
built in X Y & Z qualify me to be able
to accomplish the goals that we've
talked about in these conversations so
far so this question gives you a chance
to double down on something that you
think they want to hear about why you'd
be good in that role and might can solve
problems for them I hope that I hope
that clarifies this for you a bit Ali
thank you so much for your question
all right our next question is from
Salem how can I create a data analyst
job officially if I am dealing with a
difficult boss who does not listen to
data should I quit and shift my career
how do I evaluate my options I this is a
great question and it's kind of one of
those things because it is Valentine's
Day right so it's like you're with
someone and they don't listen to you
well how do you how do you fix that
do you have a conversation with them and
be like hey this date is important and I
feel like it's not being seen I feel
like you're not listening I feel like
maybe don't say it that way if it's your
boss but you know is there a way that
you can sit down with your boss and have
a conversation about the data that
you're seeing and how we can help solve
more problems if you can convince them
and persuade them that data this is
actually an opportunity for you to build
a skill set to build the ability to
convince someone that your data matters
right it could be that you know you you
need a little bit of work and building
up your persuasion skills so I would
maybe start there you have a boss that
doesn't listen to data is there a way
that you can convince them whether you
have a one-on-one sit-down whether you
get a group of people together to you
know put together some sort of I don't
know argument for it I'm not entirely
sure but it sounds like you have a
difficult boss who doesn't want to
listen in general if that's truly the
case and they don't value your role you
might want to start thinking about a
shift you might want to start thinking
about other companies and other bosses
because you want to work for someone who
values your opinion and same thing with
life and love right you want to be with
someone who values your opinion who
listens who understands and who tries to
incorporate the things that you come up
with into you know whatever we're trying
to work on so when you're thinking about
this if you do truly have a difficult
boss it might be time to start getting
your resume up to par and sort of
thinking about what's what's next what
how can I meet some people how can I go
to network how can I go learn and get my
get closer to a company
boss and culture that values data more
than where I'm currently at it doesn't
mean I mean it depending on how typical
your boss is you don't necessarily have
to like run for the hills right away but
there's a couple of options there one
trying to come more persuasive and get
them on your side or number two go try
and find companies that value data more
and make that switch people typically
change jobs every two to four years at
this point so switching jobs isn't isn't
a terrible thing when when you work in
the technology field and that's fairly
common alright our next question is from
OSIS what is the most important job
application advice for someone looking
to change a career hmm I'm wondering
which answer I want to give because you
asked for the most important the most
important one is you need to network
it's not an option and sorry it's not an
optional thing you have to build a
network almost all jobs are found
through personal referrals so however
you network whether it's online in
person at events with one-on-one coffees
you need to build some sort of a
connection with the companies that you
want to work for in order to succeed now
there's about a dozen other things that
I want to talk about here as well but
that is the most important thing if you
are not networking the chances of you
finding a job decrease substantially I
believe this next question is you as
well but there's no name attached to it
how can I get a remote job what is
required and is it hard to get in my
case I four years experience as an
Android developer this is a great
question but it's got a very complicated
answer I'll try and give a couple of
ideas here and then we we can kind of
see where it goes
but you know words get a remote job I I
put this question
up on LinkedIn a few months back and
created a number of videos called in our
career tip series so if you want to
check out baby pasties YouTube and go
look at those those videos definitely
check it out but most of the people that
I talked to about who work remote I work
remote most of the people that I talked
to about working remotely said that they
got their remote job by turning their
real job there in-person job into a
remote job over time so basically they
worked at a company they were doing very
well they had a great relationship with
their boss and they said you know I
really like to start doing some of this
work remote do you think that's
something we can start incorporating and
here's my plan for doing it more regular
check-ins here's how I'm going to
communicate here's how you can get in
touch with me here's the hours that I'm
going to work so you know that I'm
always on when you need me because the
biggest thing about remote work is
building trust trust with the people
that you work with so they know that
they can rely on you if questions come
up I mean if you're in a company and
they have a question they can pop by
your desk but if you're working remote
they can't pop by so you need to be
available you need to be communicating
regularly all that kind of stuff
so what these people did was they would
say all right I'm gonna work from home
one or one day a week then two days a
week then within a year I can move this
into a fully remote job where I come
into the office maybe on Wednesdays or
twice a week or however the organization
works it out so that's the typical way
that people build a remote role the
other things that you can do if you
don't have a job right now one that you
can transition into a remote job is
start looking online at what companies
hire remote workers there's actually
entire organizations or their entire
workforce is remote and so if you really
really want that if that's high priority
for you you're gonna need to do some
research you're gonna need to figure out
what companies hire remote workers it's
gonna be very difficult to convince a
company to hire you remotely if they
don't have anyone else working remote
it's also gonna be very difficult if
you're a junior in your role and they
need you to be around
to other people and getting mentorship
so it really depends on the job it
depends on the company and you're gonna
have to do a lot of research and then if
you want to be a remote worker you need
to be human online you need to build an
online presence an online brand that
will showcase that you're trustworthy
that you get things done that when I if
I'm never going to meet you in person is
there a way that I can sort of interact
with you online that makes me feel like
I can trust you that makes that builds a
rapport those are all things that are
going to be really important I know
people with like YouTube videos that
that builds rapport right it's easier to
trust me when you can see my face when
you can hear my tonality all that all
that different stuff versus you know
some random stranger who when I google
them they don't come up it's gonna be
hard to hire that person remote if you
have a blog whatever the thing might be
so those are a few ideas you said you
have four years of experience as an
Android developer start researching
companies that already hire remote
workers and then you know maybe you have
to work in person and transition or
maybe you can find those roles there's a
lot of websites maybe go to Reddit and
type in how to find remote work and
there might be lists of companies and
things of that sort
thank you for your question
all right we're getting into the last
five minutes here the first thing I want
to do before I answer our final question
is point out that there's going to be a
succeeding as a freelancer webinar oh
that's another thing for remote work if
you're a freelancer it's much easier to
work remote if you work for yourself you
can work anywhere so that might be a
path you go as well
succeeding as a freelancer webinar on
226 Karen will put the link in the chat
I highly recommend that you join this
it's going to be with the sama school
and it's really great for any of you who
are just trying to pick up some projects
build your own little business and
become a freelancer it's it's it's great
a great webinar coming up and then the
other thing is we're gonna have more of
these ask a career coach sessions in the
future so we'll be putting that link in
the chat as well so please check that
out it's going to be extremely exciting
to you know continue to bring these
these sessions to you and answer your
questions every week and then I'll jump
into our last question today see how
much I can get through all right we're
gonna end today because this is how to
find a career that you love with Matt's
question is it a flaw or just
professionalism to not be loyal to and
passionate about your company hmm this
is a very interesting question I'm sure
that there's going to be a debate about
this answer but here's some thoughts is
it a flaw or professionalism I think
that the majority of people are not
quote-unquote passionate about their
company or their work or both I think
most people have things that they're
passionate about in their life that you
know work is just part of the overall
scope right you have the person that is
your partner you have maybe family you
have maybe children you have your
educational pursuits you have maybe your
hobbies maybe you're someone who loves
like hiking and rock-climbing and you
work in order to fund that I'm not going
to judge anyone's approach to their
career I think everyone has their own
list of priorities and their job in
their work is going to fall somewhere in
that range of priorities if you're
someone who really loves to work or
really loves the work they're doing it's
very high up on your list if you're
someone who puts family over your job
maybe you you know you prioritize being
able to have a flexible work environment
where you can be home with your kids or
something like that I don't think it's a
flaw necessarily I think it's just
understanding yourself and being
self-aware enough to know what it is
that you want out of life and know what
it is you're trying to accomplish if you
want to build businesses and that's your
thing then you got to spend a lot of
time doing that if you want to focus on
your family like I said that's what you
gotta focus on I think it's not
necessarily a flaw or anything along
those lines I think it's just about
being self-aware and so of course it'd
be great if you were passionate and you
would go in every day and say you know
I'm working on something that's changing
the world but not everything changes the
world sometimes you're just creating
great experiences for people maybe you
just really like shoes and you want to
work at Nike that's cool
maybe you want to work at Nike because
you know you think they're changing the
way people interact with physical
fitness that's cool too you could be
there for the design aesthetic you could
be there for like the fitness goals
there's a lot of different reasons that
we do what we do it's about figuring out
what you want that life and figure it
and being honest with yourself about
what you're trying to accomplish and
when you know those things it becomes
much easier to motivate yourself to do
the job well and so as we talk about
this and we couch it all in our
Valentine's Day discussion finding work
you love is much more about
understanding who you are and being
happy with the decisions that you make
so take that for what it's worth
I wish you all the best one thing to
know is that we are about to jump on
Twitter in just one minute after I hang
up this call and we're gonna be doing a
Twitter chat about the same topic
finding work you love so if you want to
jump over there and chat with me a
little bit more maybe have a few more
questions answered I'm gonna be jumping
on right after this so thank you so much
for joining us today it has been
absolutely wonderful chatting about how
to find a career you love and and
digging into all of your questions I'm
sorry we didn't get to everyone's
questions today but it's just always
amazing to see where you're at see
what's on your mind and help you
overcome those barriers that are between
you and the job that you want so thank
you all and I appreciate you joining us
have a wonderful rest of the week and
happy Valentine's Day